so today we are gonna read for the food
that previously gave us food poisoning
this is why you don't tell your friends
[Music]
so I've had a couple of instances of
food poisoning but the all-time worst
one was with free cheese I freakin hate
coleslaw cold slaw it's literally the
nastiest thing I've ever had in my life
I used to love free cheese it was my
favorite kind of cheese ever since I got
food poisoning from it I haven't really
been able to eat it again I was young at
a cookout and then my cousin's younger
girlfriend you know she brought coleslaw
I was a nice kid I liked her she gave me
a lollipop so I'm like yo sis imma try
yo coleslaw I ate I even ate a whole
half a plate and as soon as I got up I
literally felt my body converging the
cold slaw like each step I felt my
stomach turn and then before you know it
I actually threw up on my dad my whole
family does scuba dive and we were
supposed to do this big scuba diving
trip in the Great Barrier Reef which was
so exciting for all of us they greeted
us at the hotel and they left out some
welcome sandwiches for us I pick up a
brie cheese sandwich and I start eating
it my sister starts to get really sick
my dad started to get sick I started to
get really sick too
I pooped myself okay you guys happy I
was a young child I grew up I pooped
myself me and my sister were sharing
this hotel room and there was only one
toilet
my sister's vomiting and then I start
feeling really sick and I need to go I
started like throwing up in the sink
vomit is not the only thing that's
coming out of four streams one
oh my god
we meet again
what's his landing like brown stuff in
this cold slow home a cold slaw I can
already smell it it's a pretty like
pungent cheese its creamy but it still
has a little bit of like a funk to it
and that kind of reminds me of the funk
of like vomit I feel my eyes watering
I'm not into this okay
it's tough to put down and still chewing
it and you don't really need to chew
cheese that's my I'm so scared to
swallow this once you get through the
initial funk I guess it's okay it's just
the memory associated with it that like
just puts me right back on that island I
don't feel like I'm going to get sick
but I haven't gotten up yet and I'm not
pooping myself at work so you know what
I'm still not gonna swallow this because
I don't want to put myself I don't like
sugary stuff and this is sweet as hell
there's just like so many other cheese's
in the world and I feel like I've just
kind of moved on like thank you next you
know in the words of cardi B I don't
speak and that just means I don't mess
with you